anti-intellectualism means to thing hate
of debate and hate of truth as a goal
which can be achieved approximatively in
a long intellectual process this is what
is hated by anti scientifically the two
things together the debate the
description the opposition of point of
view with the consideration of remote
truth this is a couple debate now truth
tomorrow and this couple is what the
anti-intellectualism of today hates most
so you have people today who defend
phonetically some fake news instead of
before you had people fighting
democratically for a remote truth again
which and completely the compass which
and completely the pattern and we are
changing of world and for me this
anti-intellectualism was is something
which which is coming from a long time
and it really paid the road in Europe
and in America for the neo populism and
Trump is not the author of that he's a
result of that he is the result of this
long anti-intellectualism and in that
the social networks of as you know big
responsibility and when when max you can
area is addressed on that when when his
question on that when he says I'm not an
historian I'm not here to make the
police of the fake his it's a joke and
it's a and it's not correct and he's not
he does not take the huge responsibility
which life gave him without being an
historian he has facebook has twitter
has a huge responsibility in not putting
the fake and the news as
same level today if you are 20 years old
if you take your informations in this
little box there is very little who can
allow you to make the difference between
the fake and the news which is the truth
and the lies very little helping to make
the difference no subtitles fake fake
should be subtitles subtitled like in
bad movies we need some tables
[Music]